僕去年頭から大量の数をかぶったんですよ
ショック療法ではず治すためにこれ本当に危ないんですよ
下手すればな引きらしい症候群で死ぬかもしれないんですけどなんか今年から花粉症が
ほぼ治りました
外したそうです足で羽根しちゃダメだよ花粉症がかなり楽あれが利いたと頭なんです
けど今年は全然行けそうです皆さんは iphone ケースどんなの使ってますか
おいらこういうのを使ってますめっちゃ線プレートを作ってるんですよこれ波動がなん
か口に呼び出してて落ちてもスマホの傷つかないような作りになっててだけっても一回
も画面はれたことないんでこのケースでずっと僕は満足してるんですけど
俺は見つけてしまった史上最強の iphone ケースを appbank さんで
買いました
このれが普通の iphone ケース遊べてるわけないっしょは同じであのもネット
で見た瞬間これだと思ってすぐ買っちゃったんですけど
はーはっはっは真っ暗
マック2杯ぐらいさんありがとうございますたぜメジャートランクて商品買ったよ
あーマッハ
はい前年していただけれこれでこちらどうですかこれ iphone 用のゲーム
コントローラー話ですね持ち手みたいな iphone 今朝見たことあるんですけど
これもそのままですからねどうやって使うんだろう
どうぞさあそうそう iphone たったった iphone あうんっ
どうぞ iphone でタッチするとか普通だからさあコントローラーとかねそ
ボタンをつけたしてで使えるかどうかって問題ってまぁちょっとちょっと気になる
ところなんですけどさすが挙げてみましょう
ファイナルファンタジー7とが入れてるんですけどあればいいしとる人はパコ
ファイナルファンタジー7は大クラウドパワーねファイナルファンタジー7は良かった
まあどうポテトみたいな応援でファイナルファンタジーしてるもいいます
ここでできますねそのファイナルファンタジー戦もスマホでインストールしたんです
けどあっちだから案の定やりに行くをたまったもんじゃない揺れねクーラーと言うこと
聞かない出身者から僕は思って何でも4でもスマホにコントローラー
水からなんて画期的なんかなーと思って今回これを手に入れましたいやースゴイねこれ
まあ直轄もん食べアーマー高まるとやばいやばいやオープン応募方法もこんな感じで
ゲーム
バイスって言うらしいですね本体オールイングリッシュ
わかんないですけど本来こんなこんなんですよ
ハッサンダメだなんて言えば再なる煩雑に7がサーッとローランてきたら上の子が感動
でこんな感じですここにライトニン警棒があるからそれここに iphone を
入れるだけです
長くねーか裏のこれで調節できるみたい操作性は月で2
のコントローラーですねやばいよこれ貼って待って待ちでマイコレ破ってペダル発で
ファイナルファンタジーきたこれはのファンだ時期たよかった
さっき買って買ったこのあっきいたパネルでキーと洒落待って取れなくなったパター
ンって何が多く一人しっかり吸っこれこういうれるわけでいいかいだーできました
こういう感じになりました iphone カチッと挟むことができてこういう感じで
ゲームコントローラー風になりました
日本語書いてある互換性のあるでゲームがあるらしいですそうかそれそうだなぁ
これでもうタントができた
本当にうれしいんですけど3年ファンタジーとができそうな気がするんだけどか
4日
とまじかん
でも盗まれたをフェリックを返すよ
ぼかぁ育った動きませ5はホット3の選択肢が動きますすごい
ちょっとコントローラーになりましたこの iphone ケースでこれケースって
いうのかなたら太陽するゲームっていうのはなんだのかだと思ってちょっと調べてみ
ましょうへと浅田でゲームはマインクラフト置いてるの
すげーアサシンクリードウォーキングデッと夫グランドセフトオートアートファイナル
版だぜセーブ
うんファイナルファンタジー iii そんな形45-6ほかにもたくさんあるんです
けどもう何役種類ゾンビゲームがあるみたいでちょっと俺はよくわかんないですね俺の
iphone 系させたからこれから
デジモンワールドとか出てこいまったく話変わるんですけどプレステのデジモン
ワールドをスマホで出てほしいですプレステのゲームでその人的にデジモンワールドが
一番面白かったからちょっと
デジモンワールド良かったのはその方で出してくださいお願いします
デジモンワールドどんなゲームかっていう中説明するは簡単にいうと自分が主人公で1
匹のデジモンを育てるゲームでそのデジモンアニメ誌をあげないとお腹続いて死んだり
しちゃうしてトイレに行きたくなるとちゃんとベンズまで連れて行かないとおもらし
そう足しすぎると汚いですもで進化してしまいますので頑張ってトイレに行かせ
5ご飯をあげながら廃れた末にいろんな土地に住むで長を呼んでね街を大きくしてい
くっていう
めっちゃ面白いですねで呪文あると回答だけ長いまで結構 iphone とかでね
空気ゲームがすごいダウンロードできて遊べるんでマジでこういう言葉が本当にボス
から出すぞ低床高まりすぎだって今日は寒い
デジモンワールドでて欲しいアプリで本当にあの1匹ので樹もうね大事に大事につれて
いる観客僕はもう1回楽しみたいです今度からすごい長松院誰からも使うと思います
じゃあ